let's face it such a scary time in the
world right now thanks to the insane
situation in North Korea and here's what
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson said
about this crisis he said that Americans
should sleep well at night that's what
he said when well you know but this
North Korean crisis said Americans
should sleep well now I am a patriot and
I want to help Americans do just that
we're on late at night and I wanted to
try this skills can you help me out I
have a guitar here and I think everyone
knows
the whole world knows I have a very
beautiful singing voice so what I'm
gonna do
don't giggle at that cuz I'm gonna sing
America to sleep right now with a
soothing lullaby because I think that's
what we need right now already Jimmy
help me out here
[Music]
hush my country go to sleep
fall into a slumber deep everything will
be okay tomorrow is a brand new day new
day new day
Kim says that he has a bomb and he's got
it aimed at Guam but that Islands far
away so screw it
I think we're okay I think we're fine
we're gonna be okay
where's Guam then again according to his
missiles just might reach assume he says
that he can hit LA and destroy the
mansion of Michael Bay Michael Bay's
rich anyway how'd we ever get this far
oh right we elected a reality star
lalala these people look insane la la la
they kind of look insane oh my god I
wish I hadn't shown this footage now I
don't think that I'll ever sleep again
this was a mistake I'm sorry oh my God
look at that
oh good lord hey don't worry though life
is great
soon we'll have the iPhone 8 don't you
worry about attacks cuz Will & Grace is
coming back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
frog
you